good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an incred amazing weekend
we're so excited to be back here hey jax
how you doing i'm doing well i too hope
your weekend was in crab we all hope you
had an encryab weekend our last weekend
of july today we enter august august
slipped away into a moment in time i
wish you would it's so funny i wish she
would august usually goes pretty quickly
or slowly depending on who you are and
where you are
i'm hoping for a brief august but i have
some fun things planned and obviously i
have so much going on right now that i
think time will slip away from me you
know i mean if you're like vacationing
at the beach or spending august in italy
like of course it's going to slip by but
if you're getting your [ __ ] ass up
and working it's going to take you know
the same amount of time to pass as any
ordinary month what you're providing the
entertainment for those vacationing and
really if you're working this month
right yeah it's going to go slowly but
for us
we have so much exciting things
happening especially today and i hate to
over promise and under deliver but
today's gonna be a transformative day
yeah yeah i'm actually vlogging the
entire day because i figured people
would want to see like claudia what the
[ __ ] are you doing down there i can't
believe you're still there claudia i
thought maybe on monday you'd be back in
your studio no i'm doing an entire day
in the life vlog because today happens
to be extremely busy not only is it
transformation day here at the morning
toast um it's also august 1st which
means i announced the final
tier dates of my unlocked tour so all
this announced yeah i did it's on
instagram thanks for following um i was
busy i can't get to the ground until
later in the day we have one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven eleven shows eleven cities added
for the final i'm so glad you asked
jackie thank you already announced west
hampton red bank in new haven those
sound premium portland in seattle
north fork no not north fork pacific
northwest
bella swan moment um long island
huntington new york you love huntington
i do and huntington loves you famed
theater where i saw casey muskrace
perform pittsburgh divine diversion
holds a special place in our hearts yes
nashville of course i'm so happy for the
nashville toaster me too i'm sorry i
neglected you but you're the star of the
second leg so would you rather be you
know a small fish in a big pond or a big
fish in a small pond it's a personal
question it is by personal then comedy
big fish in small pond obviously
charlotte and durham north carolina two
separate north carolina dates because as
previously discovered on the dirty jeans
tour north carolina is one of the better
states in this country i would say top
five for sure and then birmingham
alabama i didn't even realize like how
we're so big in alabama the toast they
need to redo that study because we would
come up for alabama oh love that yeah we
really would
i have a question so every time you
announce a tour date there's always like
people from a certain city who are like
ohio it's ohio yeah so um
let me tell you why first of all i was
gonna say there's always people from a
certain city who are like come to blank
and it's like
really the majority and the the left out
city last leg it was nashville now
nashville is taken care of so i guess
it's the ohio no ohio dates question
mark and let me tell you why um i did a
couple ohio dates um previously and i
did cleveland and i did columbus and i
think i did liberty something and they
were all comedy clubs which i love doing
comedy clubs but for me to like miss the
toast and travel like it has to be worth
my time um in terms of ticket sales so
i'm trying to do like i'm trying to do
less shows more people if that makes
sense aka bigger venues just to maximize
my time so i can be here for the toast
and also travel for tour um so
demographic wise i just don't think
there was like a big enough audience in
one particular part of ohio um and i had
such a negative experience in cleveland
last time i don't think i could go back
i don't think that's possible and you
know what i would feel bad for the ohio
toasters except for how much shine we
give to cleveland you know
we're constantly shining on cleveland
actually you are ever since i actually
went to cleveland and had like an
encounter with some probably the worst
crowd i've ever had in my life
um i won't be returning sorry i am
holding a grudge here's my theory
i feel like a lot of people seek out
comedy you know as a bright spot in an
otherwise dark
life or a dark day and i just feel like
people in cleveland are like so bright
and happy that they don't like need
comedy as a relief that's funny actually
that's a good call like people in new
york like we need it yeah no desperately
i understand what you're saying it's
just like so laid back i like how you
still say people in new york we need it
well i i've been here for a week so i'm
technically like still a new yorker
in my mindset but i really look forward
to that changing and like i'm still a
new yorker in the way that i walk like
i'm getting places fast i'm not walking
for leisure and let me tell you
something about the people here i'm
still a new yorker in the way that i
talk let me tell you something about the
people here in florida
when i say that they're in absolutely no
rush to do or get anywhere it is
shocking that's probably for me the
biggest culture shock you never really
noticed it because every time i'm here
i'm on vacation
so i don't mind everyone being slow but
here i'm working i'm trying to go to
fedex get something printed everyone is
just like molasses yeah it's shocking so
i do look forward to those changes in
myself i'm sure i'll always have like a
new york way about me but
i am so hurried in everything that i do
and i do need to take a chill pill yeah
so for the tickets patreon members are
gonna get um pre-sale obviously that
starts on wednesday all the details are
on my instagram and then if you're not a
patreon member that's friday general on
sale for everybody so i really hope to
see you guys there this is the same show
as the beginning of the year just
different cities so if you haven't
gotten a chance to see it this is your
final chance
and if you have gotten a chance to see
it and you loved it so much like come
see it again and bring a friend like
spread the power of the toast and if she
isn't coming to your city i would
recommend
getting the girls together
for a like a weekend of end log because
if she's not gonna do this show any
further and she's saying i think you
mean that when you say that like oh no
it's fully done at the end of the year
it's worth like getting your [ __ ] ass
up and going and making a weekend of it
because it's really great stuff um not
to like switch gears so completely but i
wanted to touch on something that we
spoke on last week which was your
mispronunciation of the material of
these
chairs right
so allegedly somebody messaged me or
maybe it was on tick tock they let me
know that we did an ad recently for like
a furniture company um and i was
describing all of the gorgeous
materials in which the company offers
furniture and one of those was buckle
and i did say boogle so maybe that's why
it was in your head
maybe no it's just we both read it
we both pronounced it the way that it's
read and you obviously like
became classy in the time since but i'm
still you know no but i like being an
uncultured swine but i like how i like
sat here and i was like it's boucle what
about even more immediate when you
corrected me for candace cameron beret
and i was wrong and then not only that
but then throughout the rest of the
story you called her cameron beret not
even what you told me to call her and
you were wrong you know what i think is
important like really genuinely i think
it's important that um nobody like
learns anything from this show like you
know what i mean i so disagree like we
are so disagree we are not you know
english teachers we're not english
majors like we are not going to be
teaching you
other than life's important lessons i
mean like actual like
grammar or you know what i mean you know
i feel like in every episode you could
find like one interesting factoid that
we delivered i feel like in every
episode like you can take away like an
important life lesson like we're talking
too yeah but i don't think like you know
um
like you're gonna be taking away like
facts you know no i think you could get
some facts you could also get
some non-facts
fiction right but i don't think that's
fair to say oh overwhelmingly like
sometimes i show up with a titanic fact
that's true like there's things like
that yeah and or yesterday on the
patreon like about the i-95 that goes
through the whole country right okay um
okay and the i stands for interstate and
you can go through states right that is
what interstate means when you think
about it but no one thinks about it
nobody thinks about it i got on the i-95
i was we did a podcast episode yesterday
catching up with olivia
you know life in florida michaela it was
a great episode um and i told the story
about how you know last week when i was
like running around town trying to
like do the most i accidentally ended up
on i-95 which was the scariest
expressway freeway interstate that i'd
ever been on in my life and i didn't
understand why i was on the [ __ ]
freeway i was going literally 10 minutes
away to fedex like i wasn't going
that far it was horrifying i never saw a
freeway that big and i drive on the
highway a lot like
but in new york i guess we're limited to
like four or five lanes this was dead
ass 20 lanes like front it was so crazy
a lot of people traveling interstate and
that's why i really kind of um
sympathize with dion
from clueless like it's [ __ ] freaky
especially in a convertible
yeah
um so tour
wednesday patreon pre-sale all the
details are on my instagram friday for
everyone else and i hope to see you guys
there
and we've got a great show
we do have a great show the stories are
really good i'm really excited plus we
had a great weekend so we have that
schwa de vivre that only a great weekend
can bring yeah did you watch or consume
a lot of content this weekend only reds
still haven't turned on a tv in my house
there's absolutely no rush to do so i
finished the redheads book i'm not sure
if i finished it on friday but it's
amazing a flicker in the dark by stacy
willingham like all the girls are amped
up about it we are recording this week
so if you have questions about the book
or just like books in general head over
to the redheads book club gmail.com send
us an email ask us your question then we
have snitch's choice coming up she's
between two books now
because the book she was gonna choose
it's an obvious choice but then she came
to me and she was like i think i'm gonna
choose this book and it's like kind of a
departure for snitch and like we love
that for her she never wants to depart
and so i feel like i have to encourage
that yeah i also saw she like out on her
be real she was reading the book that i
thought she was gonna choose which it
would be a little early for her to yeah
that's not allowed yeah so she's not
choosing it she was violating so she's
not choosing it is what i'm saying oh
okay well it is up to her and it's her
choice and we empower choices uh so we
shall see but then i also started a
celebrity memoir called uppercut by
carrie white who was a celebrity
hairstylist in like the 60s in hollywood
and at first lauren bostic recommended
it to me so i always take
recommendations from her seriously
because she recommended good morning
monster which really like changed how i
think yeah no big deal no um so and she
was like you would love this and at
first i was like it's weird to be
reading a memoir from someone i don't
know
like i've not heard of but now in
reading it it's like
everyone she's talking about
you do know right and it's actually
pretty cool and it's really well written
and her story is crazy so i is it
written recently
2011. but then she passed away a few
months ago oh so so it's timely right
right and i'm immensely enjoying
actually i just want to get through it
because i want to like read more books
because i'm jealous of you yeah i've
read like seven books while i'm down
here which pretty much is like a book a
day um and i read a lot this weekend
no big deal nothing to really like quake
over but i did watch the shania twain
documentary on netflix and i really just
wanted to recommend it to everyone
because of course like you know we know
shania of course we grew up with shania
we just like we love her we should we
saw her perform jonas bro she brought
that out nick jonas said stagecoach
which was weird um
but i guess i never really have sat down
and like thought about her as
a whole if that makes sense and like
really um her impact and her reach like
and i guess it was because it was a
little bit before our time but
but like when her she had two albums or
maybe three albums go diamonds like in a
row and like
it was just like actually i never really
sat back and thought about like how big
she was or like how impressive her
accolades are and the documentary
basically did that for you i did i loved
it i did feel like they left out like
the most important part which was and
she talked about her divorce how her
husband left her for another woman but
like they didn't talk about how shania
actually ended up marrying that other
woman's husband because they both were
so you know upset over their spouses
leaving them that they fell in love
while grieving like that was so
interesting so there were like chunks
missing from her personal life and then
also me and olivia you know olivia like
sluthio
she we were reading her wikipedia page
and it was just like a lot of um
not that wikipedia is 100 factual but
like on her upbringing i don't know why
it wouldn't be
um
there was a lot of
like what's the word not contradictions
but like when two things aren't adding
up like they're not the same
like hi uh
like
what she said in the world
yeah what's the word hypocrisy no no
like
contradictions then no but it's like one
plus one equals stock kind of okay so
like in the documentary she said like
this is how my upbringing was and then
in wikipedia it was like kind of
different
i would trust her documentary over
wikipedia i don't know but like
wikipedia was citing interviews she had
done it was just like really actually
confusing um and i i think she had a
really did you go read those interviews
or you just looked at the citation yeah
the interview was basically about um
how she so her mom
her dad left her mom when they were
really really young and her mom got
remarried and ended up like having more
kids with him and he adopted shania and
so in her documentary she i know um in
the interview she was like i will always
refer to him as my dad like he was there
for me like
basically defending her dad but then in
the documentary she was like i grew up
in a really violent household so it was
contradictory contra okay but maybe
when she said that interview like
she wasn't ready to share the actual
truth and that's what a documentary is
for perhaps it was just um and then like
she had brothers
and she was talking about her brothers
because both of her parents
ended up dying in a car crash when she
was like 18 and she became the sole
provider she started singing at a casino
and that's like how she kind of got in
the in the scene but she was immediately
responsible for her brothers um and she
kept saying her brothers are brothers
brothers but she also had sisters
that's what i found out on wikipedia so
i just felt like there was a lot of um
confusion on my end about her upbringing
because it was it was really interesting
like the way she grew up her mom would
sneak her out of the house to like sing
at bars but she could only sing at like
two in the morning when it was last call
because she was literally 12 and she
couldn't be in a place that was like
serving alcohol yeah um it was really
interesting and then once she hits it
big like you really forget how many
iconic songs she like has that you know
that you grew up on it and it really the
documentary left me with like respect
for
shania that's what a good doc should do
she really is that [ __ ] like she's so
she's queen like and they had a really
interesting celebrities in it obviously
like kelsey ballerini which made sense
but like diplo
it was like weird okay now i want to
watch it
i will say though that added to the play
the editing on the documentary was
giving imovie microsoft word paint like
with font that was like you know switch
it looks like one of our patreon vlogs
like i love that it was just um
in my opinion a low production value
from the editing standpoint but um
and the whole time you're like her voice
when she talks like in her you know
confessionals in the documentary she
sounds like she's on the verge of tears
the entire time and you're like why does
she sound like that then at the end she
talks about how she had lyme disease and
it literally ripped her voice from her
her voice like never recovered it's
better obviously she thought she would
never be able to like sp sing or speak
and she can but it like forever changed
the way that the sound of her voice
sounds it was weird it was crazy really
good and i just like now i'm like
obsessed i followed her on instagram
and i'm just like obsessed great we
should see her in vegas i would love to
i bet it's a real
there are so many i know people in
places just added to the list that we
gotta say yeah we gotta see keith's
urban in vegas
kelly clarkson should she choose to
grace the town with her presents carrie
underwood but me and olivia when we were
watching the documentary they had
footage of her show
in vegas and it was wild like she had
horses it was like production value 50.
how can she do a vegas show if she can't
sing like she's well so she can
but it's it's different but she she
worked she did like she took like years
off yeah and the first song she came
back to sing was this duet with lionel
richie and lionel was in the documentary
and he's like pee domination um so it's
it's back but it's
never gonna be the same okay that's but
there was like a period of time where
she thought she would never sing again
and it was like very debilitating for
her emotionally um but it made me think
when i was watching those clips of her
vegas show like there's nothing vegas
can't put together because her show was
wild like the things me and olivia we
were like adele could like adele would
never have a live horse because shania
is a pop star she does like big flashy
no it was just i was like oh it's now i
can't think of literally a show in vegas
without thinking of a doll yeah and the
excuse and the excuse yeah that isn't
holding up yeah
i feel that so it was a highly recommend
documentary if you're shania girly and
even if you're not like you will have
respect and like talk about someone who
is more sickening in like well she still
is but like when she was the it girl of
the moment like she was everything like
her outfits her glam she had that like
classic 90s hair that was like bouncy
and curly and it was just everything it
was so good like you would love it and
she looked so much like a young friend
dresher i kept watching the documentary
and like i'm like
why is there dress shirt on this and
it's shania so good i highly recommend
you would love it
add to the plate this is not my plate
but added to the plate yeah and if
you're looking for something to watch i
really um i liked it a lot she liked the
beat i liked the beat i did i'm speaking
of things i like do you know what today
is
august 1st monday the one year
anniversary the birthday the one
first birthday of sprit society it's so
exciting is that crazy it's been a year
it's crazy how much happens in a year
like where spritz is
one year later i know and we have so
much to celebrate we do and so we're
gonna do today's monday obviously so
we're gonna do unburden yourselves
um but we're going to do a little
anxiety hangover themed
unburdening yourselves in honor of
spritz's first birthday and obviously
today's lead in sponsor is spirit
society because why wouldn't it be so
should we lead in we should lead in
because there's a special surprise on
the spirit society website
okay so without further a do
do you wear the stripes brothers they're
right here being so perfect sleeping
what's the word for the way the
grandparents slept
sufficient sleeping sufficiently here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
be like that's a fact you just learned
on the morning toast tonight so decent
means to sleep the way the grandparents
slept yeah sure one person like me
didn't know the word i don't know why i
know that word it's great i think
because when we were kids we would all
like get into bed together and we would
sleep sufficiently yeah i don't know if
that's like the right ad adverb no
you're killing it um
who said i wasn't an english major
all right so today's episode is brought
to you by sprit society birthday season
is here a year ago we created our iconic
sparkling cocktails with your help
at spread society so we have our four
original flavors which is grapefruit
blood orange pineapple and lemon and our
newest launch peach you've been with us
every step of the way and this month yes
we're giving ourselves an entire month
for our birthday very margaret energy
you can celebrate with our exclusive
founders birthday bundle so birthday
bundles include two four packs of ben
claudia and jackie's favorite flavors
along with a customized insulated wine
tumbler and all of our favorite recipes
from our fabulous first year you can
shop the favorites today for a limited
time only while supplies last and
actually those tumblers were in jackie's
house not two days ago we signed all of
them jackie signed a bunch i signed a
bunch ben signed a bunch and if you go
onto the website you can choose which
bundle you want the tumblers are custom
so they're obviously are signed by us
but they're custom spritz society
insulated tumblers they're so cute they
come in different colors the birthday
bundle is on the website now check it
out and don't miss out because first of
all it's a great price for
what you're getting into like custom
signatures that'll be worth a lot one
day no and those are the best tumblers
for drinking wine out of like
they stay cold they stay cold that's the
insulation i don't know if you knew that
yeah another thing you learned here at
the morning toast
um also i would be remiss i would be
devastated i would be heartbroken if i
didn't let everyone here know that the
second sponsor of today's episode is
honestly when you say it so many times
in the song you start to like develop a
full-blown list
i know like i'm afraid it's gonna stick
if i keep going no i know that's what
makes it so much fun
the power of thuma the power of thuma
thuma practice is an intentional lessons
more design philosophy for the bedroom
with clean lines subtle curves and
lifestyle enhancing details thuma proves
that simplicity is the truest form of
sophistication introducing the bed by
thuma hand crafted from eco-friendly
high quality upcycled wood you'll
find beautiful and unique variations in
the natural grain the minimalist design
features japanese joinery helps elevate
any space it's super supportive for your
mattress it's breathable and it's made
to naturally minimize noise and create
space i hear that one of your guest
rooms has a zuma
tell me about that experience okay it's
actually been an amazing experience
first of all i know we talk about zuma
every day on the toast but if you get
the targeted ads for sumo which everyone
does they send to me the way that the
beds actually get put together is like
so seamless and genius and probably
saving marriages across the country
because you don't have to fight about it
it's so easy to put together so i got a
thuma for my guest bedroom that's called
snitch's room and i got the espresso uh
bed frame with the white linen headboard
and i'm just like think it's such a
gorgeous
look it's a cinchy vibe and it's a
snitchy vibe they also offer other
bedroom essentials to elevate bedtime
like the nightstand the side table and
the tray and they are perfect
compliments to the bed so you can create
that feeling of checking into your
favorite boutique hotel suite but at
home with the bed by thuma and now you
can go to thuma dot co that's t-h-u-m-a
dot c-o
slash toast to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping on the continental us go
to thuma dot co slash toast that's t h u
m a dot c o slash toast for a 25
credit
great thank you for that
our first story is like some drama
florence pug
pug i don't know i don't know what i
think it's pu but i don't know where i
got that that's yeah pew okay florence
pew is unhappy over olivia wilde and
harry styles is a pharah sorcered have
you seen this i have seen like people um
speculating that she's like not on good
terms with them because she's barely
promoted the movie and she's like a
she's an actress who promotes her own
movies you know yeah and so they're
actually all gonna be on the venice film
festival carpet in a few weeks promoting
the movie so we'll see then but sources
are saying that
florence is not happy with olivia this
is what the source said quote i can tell
you for a fact that flo seeing olivia
and harry all over each other on set to
olivia and harry all over each other is
literally auntie and nephew loves it's
john's not incest disgusting it's love
jon snow and daenerys yeah i can tell
you for a fact that flo seeing olivia
and harry all over each other on set did
not go down well as olivia was still
with jason when she first hooked up with
harry one insider told page six at the
time at the time of
jason sedakis and olivia wilde split
sources cited olivia wilde's
relationship with harry styles is the
main reason for the split with one
insider telling page six that the affair
with harry had it been ongoing for a
month leaving jason sedakis distraught
and so i guess florence
pugh is
upset over what she saw on set and
adultery okay can i just say that i'm
really not the biggest fan of olivia
wilde and harry mostly because i'm
jealous um
but like
no it's giving lawrence yeah florence is
giving like karen energy like okay do i
endorse adultery no but like calm the
[ __ ] down she's giving like moral
superiority yeah well i feel like it's a
few things first of all does she know
jason sedakis like personally right her
uncle or something like get out
why does she care so much agreed but i
also feel like and i can't speak for
florence i don't know her if it were me
though all i can say like i'm starring
in a movie with harry styles we're about
the same age of course single of course
or is she she's dating the zack brown
doctor from scrubs yeah yeah and
anyways i'm starting a movie with harry
styles i'm hoping if there's gonna be an
onset romance i'm hoping it's me of
course if he starts dating the married
director i'm going to take out merge
with that and whether they were engaged
not married so i do believe the rumors
that like florence pew is like butthurt
about something and i honestly did not
think it was as simple as this because
this is like really kind of weird like
it's just it's not your business like to
be completely frank and to stop talking
to everyone and not promote the movie
because like you even if you've been
personally affected by infidelity like
it's not your [ __ ] business so i was
hoping for more there and maybe the
source is like not 100 informed maybe
they're not but the and i know you can't
like trust sources especially like
anonymous sources and talk to media
outlets but like hearse i'm assuming
this source is a woman i don't know why
saying i can tell you for a fact that
flow seeing olivia like close enough to
call her flow
i didn't know her friends but that does
but that is something that like a fake
source would think about you know like
well she didn't say live because if i
was selling you know a fact about you to
the media which which don't put don't
put it past me i would do that in a
desperate time i would say i could tell
you for a fact jax is not harry's mom
that's what i'd say okay i'd say there's
more there look into it but would you
say for i could tell you for a fact
i mean that is like a weird way of
phrasing something it's very
conversational
i don't know like i definitely agree
that there's
florence is mad about something but i
don't know if i would take everything
this source says like a hundred percent
face value it's it's giving it's getting
lies
who could the source be someone who
works on the movie
okay if someone who works on the movie
wouldn't maybe they would know the truth
so it's either someone from florence's
camp in which case why would they say
something not true like this and it
wouldn't be someone from olivia and
harry's camp like shining light on the
infidelity well so that's the other
thing about this that i wanted to talk
about i guess i don't really think about
you know their relationship that much
but it wasn't my understanding
that um this relationship is what broke
her and jason sedakis up i thought they
had been like separated for a while so
did i but apparently not
like it's it's possible that like this
was the straw that made olivia leave but
i don't think she was never thinking
about leaving met harry and bounced
like i think things were bad and then
she started to fall for someone else
like that's typically what happens so
that's not infidelity by the way yeah
well there was a quote from um you can't
break up a happy marriage 100 that's
from like housewives that's margaret
joseph by the way it's so true you can't
break up a happy marriage jason um but i
feel like jason sedegas like did come
out on top afterwards like with ted
lasso and then he kind of became like a
victim and everyone felt bad for him and
isn't he dating someone now like a young
girl yeah
and i don't think like the people like
in the public like particularly like
olivia wilde as it pertains to her
relationship with harry styles you think
so i mean i know harry's fans do not
like her jealous yeah but i feel like
overall people are obsessed with them i
feel like people are obsessed with them
oh i don't feel that that's funny maybe
they are i don't feel that way
maybe it's like an obsession not
necessarily meaning we love them but we
just i can't look away i think perhaps a
lot of women with kids um
like are inspired by her because isn't
that just the dream you know yeah you
get to raise your kids with like a
stable guy and then and who's also like
your kids is idol yeah and who's also
like handsome yeah but then like when
things start to get rocky you fall into
the arms of a pop star right i'm sorry
and that's where i said who's your kids
is idol right who's your kid's his idol
yeah but like you had a great partner
for like the hard part and then like
things you know when the kids get older
things start to get easier and then like
you fall into the arms of literally the
biggest rock star in the world that's
like kim and pete
right
but i don't think people find kim
relatable but i think people might find
it to be a wild relatable why
um there's just like an aura of kim i
find kim more relatable just because she
shares more i couldn't find olivia wilde
i mean i don't follow her so i can't
critique how much she shares but i just
feel like i don't have a peek inside her
life so how can i relate to it no
totally but i think we're like a little
bit more um in pop culture than others
like
like we're a little too in the weeds
like i think for the most part people
love kim but i don't think they would
say she's relatable but like we consume
everything she puts out so we know that
she is do you know what i mean yeah and
i think on the surface she doesn't seem
relatable right right the poor just
glances and that but once you get to
know her like she is like the way she
talks about like her struggles with her
weight like i completely agree with you
yeah but i just don't think most people
like who are outside of our like
obsession with pop culture
would say like who's a celebrity you
relate to kim kardashian you know who's
the celebrity that you relate to
probably um
marilyn monroe no probably uh
let me think let me think about this
yeah it's a good question and so give me
a real answer i'm going to think too
it does depend on where i'm at in my
life
but that's like what influencers are for
right they're meant to be actually
relatable yeah
i don't know what celebrity i relate to
because like
who is hilarious
gorgeous
stunning
honestly nobody you know oh you know
what celebrity i really do myself
because i'm famous i think i can take
the time to answer by the way no at
first i was trying to think of a joke
like like a supermodel but then i'm like
okay like that's not funny like and then
i was actually thinking like a real
answer but honestly i don't scroll
through social media and be like wow
this celebrity is relatable i don't
think i've actually ever had that
thought in my life really yeah i feel
like there's no one celebrity that i
think is the relatable celebrity and
when there is i think then it's like
false it's pr busy phillips like it's
getting crazy yeah it's giving press but
there are celebrities who have moments
that i find relatable of course of
course like when they actually share
something that's like like kylie on the
treadmill right she's having a hard time
right right right yeah okay cool glad we
unpacked that but um i do feel like
there's more to this florence flow story
and um actually i'm curious like what
the deal is i think that it's this like
if there was gonna be someone who was
gonna romance harry styles on the set of
this movie it was gonna be me it was
gonna be like the hot new actress in
town you cheated yeah on me
yeah yeah i agree and you cheated me
yeah 100 percent i'm not saying that's
how flow feels i'm saying that's how i
would feel right this was supposed to be
like my press relationship my moment
yeah like we fell in love on set that
made the movie amazing right not like
he's looking behind the camera at the
director the whole time what about me
what about me what about my needs what
about flow 100
are you ready for our next story yeah
exciting news dwayne johnson is tweezing
bad blood taylor's version on tick tock
have you seen this he's tweezing that's
somebody said i said teasing you said
tweezers i'm pretty sure i said teasing
said tweezing it's fun okay i'll
remember this i remember
he's teasing that bad blood taylor's
version is going to be on his new movie
dc league of super pets with kevin hart
who then kevin teased that message in a
bottle taylor's version is also going to
be on the movie okay i [ __ ] love
message in a bottle um and this is so
taylor like i feel like now that her
songs are being released and she is
trying to like own them more she's
putting her
uh
new ethically sourced music in so many
other um projects projects like she's
actually it's a lot of like kids cartoon
movies like that's where the money is
that's where the money is and you know
what i love that for her like love love
love um
message in a bottle such a good song and
anything involving the rock me and ben
were actually having like a conversation
with the raw about the rock yesterday
because ben said he thinks that um like
the rock is gonna run for office
and like he's such a good business
person like he would be great and
everyone loves him yada yada and i'm
like okay for sure for sure but like
when i think of the by the way i like
the rock this is not like a negative
thing about the rock but when i think
about the rock like i don't think like
genius business person do you
no
maybe he is a genius business person but
i would say that he's like the top of
his field in the acting business realm
in terms of like obviously he's a good
actor but also choosing the right
project right and he and ben was telling
me being like the guy and having a great
image ben was telling me like all these
companies he's a part of because he has
a tequila company that ben says kills it
i have never heard of it and all these
different like a power drink or
something and i'm like no for sure like
he's a really um like smart celebrity
when it comes to like his money and
things to invest in like i wouldn't
think of him as like an amazing
businessman no that's i just thought it
comes to mind like a household name
family friendly great brand great image
great actor nice guy probably yeah okay
so i'm glad you agree with me yeah but
that has nothing to do with whether or
not he would be a good candidate for
office yeah no i think that was like but
what people are saying is a great
businessman like really that's just not
what comes to mind for me
yeah just like i thought but it's nice
to know about his business ventures yeah
no ben is always talking about his
tequila company like because they sell
like crazy amounts of cases per year
yeah like i feel like ashton kutcher is
like actor but great businessman yeah i
think when i you know funny enough when
dwayne johnson i think that about kevin
hart
especially after watching his
documentary like you realize how every
project he does like he owns the
production company that does it he owns
the uh car service company that drives
him to like he owns everything that's
like that's like rhys exactly
love that yeah um but back to this story
so taylor's putting her music and
taylor's also been in the news quite a
bit is that story do you know what i'm
talking about
okay this jets yeah that's not a story
so this twisted like and i'm and by the
way i am like taylor swift denier until
i die so take that with a grain of salt
but like this is actually how i feel
this like completely unreliable like
piece of [ __ ] like student uk tabloid
released some data that they concocted
themselves in a cauldron that um a list
of the celebrities in the world who you
know pollute the climate the most with
their jets
and because everyone's been talking
about kylie recently taking 10 minute
flights instead of driving 30 minutes
but the truth is those 10 minute flights
are to park her jet at the hangar
there's no way to know that for sure but
like i thought that that's what it was
that's what everyone was saying and i'm
pretty sure like something with drake
and he confirmed that yeah by the way
for sure but there's also no like full
confirmation that kylie didn't take a
10-minute flight instead of just driving
45 minutes to downtown you know okay um
so it's been in the conversation in the
news a lot like just celebrities like
you know not caring about the
environment with their jets which is
true personally like i don't really care
like if you're a celebrity who's going
to tell me not to use plastic straws and
then you're getting on your jet like
that i take umbrage like i never want to
see adrienne right on a jet in his life
if he ever flies private like he will he
be hearing for me because i am i am
doing my part without the plastic straws
i am but you're not yeah i agree with
you so if you're gonna be like a climate
girly this is like where it applies to
like leonardo dicaprio megan and harry
like
big climate girlies who would you these
are full of contradictions right who are
like really like
taking planes the most like remember
when leonardo dicaprio flew jetblue mint
as like press because he was getting so
he was at like unicef at the un being
like climate climate climate and then
literally the way he got home from that
climate unicef event was on his plane
like that that [ __ ] really bothers me
but whatever i digress so this i don't
even know what the website's called but
like it's a wholly unreliable website
that released this um article here are
the celebrities who are you know
contributing the worst the most bad
amount to the environment with their
planes and obviously everyone was like
kylie kylie kylie but then number one
turned out to be taylor swift and kylie
didn't even crack the top ten correct
there was definitely a kardashian on
there i don't know actually i guess if
you put the whole family together the
only piece of information that like
really made its way out was the fact
that taylor swift was number one mm-hmm
and so her quaking flooding in the memes
are flooding and like
it's very possible taylor swift is the
number one you know climate
abuser
but um why are we all just believing
this random
unverified
janky website like like it's fact
yeah since when like i never heard of
this it says that marketing firm yard
compiled the list using data from
twitter account called celebrity jets oh
which imports from the adsb exchange
which is the largest public source of
unfiltered so it was a research study
with information from twitter
oh then it has to be true
i want to see the list
taylor's uh rep did respond basically
saying like
taylor
by the way i think taylor has multiple
planes um
and that taylor charters like she
doesn't fly half of those flights she
gets she makes money on her plane by
chartering it out to other rich people
so she's not responsible for every
single month that's a good every single
omission even if she's given like one
flight away yeah she could say that no
and i'm sure she does and by the way i
know she has like one major big plane
that has like 13 written everywhere it's
like sewn into the seats i don't think a
lot of people charter that plane but i
know she has she owns a bunch of hangers
in nashville she makes a lot of money
from her planes because they're really
expensive to keep up she's another
celebrity who i would say is like
incredibly um business savvy
yes like she owns the production
companies that produce her music videos
like she's one of those celebrities yeah
celebrity
um
so yeah this this story just like
bothered me because
and you know what i will say like at
least taylor is not like patronizing all
of us with like instagram posts about
how we all need to stop living wasteful
lives
shorter showers colder showers use that
water for coffee and eat bugs right like
that [ __ ] bothers me like look in the
mirror look in the mirror like every
celebrity who's posting about climate
change like you literally have to fly
commercial like that should be a rule no
you have to take a sailboat yeah like
it's so hypocritical so
it's possible taylor is actually the
number one contributor even though i
just like have a hard time believing it
because she doesn't even do she doesn't
even work ever like she's always just
chilling you know so how much can she
actually be flying if most of the time
she's chilling at home like especially
recently she's only been working like a
couple times a year
so i don't know if i really believe that
but even if that's true i'm grateful
she's not like one of the celebrities
he's like always yelling at us to do
more yes
here's the list okay taylor's number one
allegedly number two is floyd mayweather
okay
okay number three is jay-z
um number four is a-rod
number five is blake shelton
number six steven spielberg
seven kim even though she just got her
place right she must be doing actually
that makes sense she's always on the
move yeah
uh next is mark wahlberg
then oprah and then travis scott
top ten
i'm just trying to think of like any of
these celebrities are
real environment activists like but none
of them really come to mind when i think
all celebrities are but yes but some are
more passionate than others
when i think i really think of leonardo
dicaprio megan and harry
yeah
and adrian grenier obviously
so um it does make me feel better like
i can't stand that [ __ ] like
it's hypocrisy it's like everyone let's
turn off our light bulbs for 35 minutes
like some of us have to go to work okay
we can turn up our light bulbs yeah some
of us have to film a show we need
some of us are just ugly
are you ready for our next story
no okay
um theo i love you more than life itself
but i'm gonna let you go like oh stress
i'm just like getting uncomfortable but
i love you dearly um okay so where was i
today's episode who is it brought to you
by just
oh actually
did i already do
i'm sorry i'm like the worst
you don't have your curds that's why i
don't know my curds because you and
olivia don't have i have printers i have
an excuse
just you just move yeah olivia being a
businesswoman working mom not having a
printer is disgraceful um and once kayla
like starts to get homework she's gonna
need to get it printed for sure but
she's just like saving trees
i got it oh my god sorry theo just
scared me i don't know what he's doing i
got you there um today's episode is
brought to you by lollipop you know we
are soda girlies through and through we
love it and there's a new kind of soda
that tastes amazing and is actually good
for you so lollipop is a new kind of
soda it tastes just like the sodas we
grew up with but unlike other sodas that
are full of sugar corn syrup and
artificial ingredients like aspartame
oli pop is made with natural ingredients
that are actually good for you and
lollipop is the fastest growing
functional beverage brand in america
they have delicious
nostalgic flavors like vintage cola
classic root beer orange squeezed cherry
vanilla strawberry vanilla and their
newest flavor classic grape i forgot to
tell you ben came home like two weeks
ago and he was like
have you ever had holy pope and i'm like
i'll come again he's like this soda is
like so good i'm like literally the
response of the show we have had it in
the studio you've drank it at the studio
a thousand times and why are you saying
it like that like it's ollie pop he's
like it's so good and it's only pope i'm
like oh yeah okay sure um
so it actually is really good um it does
taste a lot like those classic flavors
when you think of like old diners like
cream soda things like that um i happen
to really like the classic root beer and
i'm not actually ever really been a
rooty or girly
but the flavors are really good you can
find something that definitely suits
your
your palette they have such great
flavors and all different vibes you know
depending on what you're eating
or sometimes you want something like
refreshing with little ginger a little
lemon
and they're so confident that you'll
love their products that they're
offering 100 money-back guarantee for
orders placed to their website so you
can receive 20 off plus free shipping on
your order
we definitely recommend the variety pack
it's a great way to try all of their
delicious flavors when you go to drink
lollipop dot com slash toast or use code
toast at checkout to claim the deal the
website is drink ollie pop d r i n k o l
i p o p dot com slash toast lollipop can
also be found in over 8 000 stores
across the country including walmart
target kroger whole foods sprouts and
publix that's some good distribution
yeah
love that
i love ballet
i love publix i really do too are you
ready for our next story some drama
already beyonce dropped a new album on
friday called a renaissance have you
seen the drama
and she's being put in your
she's being slammed by fans and
disability charity scope for including
the ableist slur that lizzo just dropped
from her song beyonce like have you
learned nothing so beyonce has been
called out by disability equality
charity scope for using an ableist slur
on her new song heated this comes just
weeks after lizzo apologized for using
the same word on her song girls and had
her track re-recorded so beyonce has the
lyrics in her song um
i'm not gonna say that i i value my
career my job i love this show so um i
thought you were gonna say because
people are like citing this one
like lyric from one of the beyonce songs
it must be the cash because it ain't
your face
um and people think that's her like
calling jay-z ugly and rich
and everyone's using the song like for
um like jokey meme types and it's really
funny i didn't know that she used that
this s word and i have to imagine of
course beyonce doesn't like keep up with
the news and know that like this
happened to lizzo but i am sure one of
the people who works with her like
either a producer help songwriter
someone on
her team like they know about it i think
they know and i think beyonce definitely
before she put this out like knew that
it was like a trigger not a trigger like
a controversial word um and decided to
stick with it so i don't think we'll be
seeing a re-release like lizzo did like
beyonce made a decision and she's
telling everyone they could [ __ ] off
yeah no i think the choice was made i
don't think that she i'm sure i'm sure
she keeps up enough even if beyonce like
didn't necessarily know the story like
the people on her team did like pr
people
was chosen i'm sure they said to beyonce
like just so you know this is what's
happening about the word and she said
leave the word so obviously don't say
the word but like what's the context
what's the lyric um
okay so the word is s star star everyone
knows no they don't last time we were
talking about it they were there was a
post like what word are you guys talking
about okay okay s star star z
um the middle letters are pa and the
word can mean to freak out or go crazy
in the u.s but it's very widely known
that it comes from the word [ __ ]
so it says
bleep on that ass bleep on that ass
got it so she wants you to go wild on
that house yeah that's some good advice
by the way um you should go wild on that
ass um
okay like
i don't know i feel like
beyonce really can do no wrong for a lot
of people
so i don't really feel like this is
going to have legs like
the thing with beyonce is like
like nobody cares like we're just
grateful for the music we're grateful
for no one like she puts out an album
like it's a it's a work of art it's a
masterpiece there's no editing the art
what is she gonna take the track off of
itunes and spotify no that's also not
beyonce's like
vibe like she puts that work and then
she goes back into under her shell like
she doesn't interact publicly she
doesn't really do social media so
i don't think she really gives a [ __ ]
and like these things happen and they
pass so quickly and i think people's
overall sentiment is like they're just
excited about the album yeah but i don't
it's an interesting precedent for the
word because now it's like
we can't use it right
set the precedent and changed it so we
were all like okay this word is
officially out but then beyonce who is
you know obviously more influential than
lizzo only in the sense that she's you
know more famous and been around for for
longer um beyonce said it was okay so i
don't know
i personally am just like staying away
from it because it's not a word i really
ever use it's not gonna be one that i
have to like stop saying
um
it's kind of like we said this last time
it's like kind of like a losery word
like
to to use like when you're using it in
that context like there's just better
words you can use like
go wait [ __ ] i don't know you know what
i mean
um
so my life remains unaffected which is
really all i care about
yeah yeah but i just care about the
precedent and now president me is
confused yeah no you're precedented for
sure like you're always looking to
precedent for you know guidance yeah the
president has been contradicted
so i guess it's just do what you think
is best i like that precedent right i
like life for precedent
i think it's more clear in countries
that aren't america like whether the
word is good or bad and here it's just
like extremely confusing yeah
anyways oh you should know i didn't know
that that's so interesting
our next story the cma awards are on
november 9th and we have our hosts
i'm looking at your ipad is that peyton
manning luke bryan and peyton manning
are hosting the country music awards in
november
will we be on the red carpet who knows
um
we'll have to see if it conflicts with
any of my tour dates and if you're able
to get away from roll day yeah i would
love to yeah that's well that's like
good every time we do this story every
year it reminds me the house come up in
like august september and it reminds us
like we need to get on our stuff i
actually really like peyton manning
being selected as a um host because
and i think a lot of people would be
like what the [ __ ] this random like
football player but he's actually
extremely entertaining like i think one
of his um
snl episodes is like widely regarded as
one of the better like maybe even the
best hosting jobs ever definitely by any
professional athlete he's like super
funny and
entertaining like good at reading
teleprompters i think he will be good i
think he'll be good too and luke bryan
is like a tv darling these days yeah
don't slander him no i'm not i actually
recently like come to love him i love
him i think he's great on american idol
i like his music enough i just feel like
and this is my personal problem with
country music is like
the like the biggest male stars in
country music they're just like
statues like they don't move it's like
blake shelton jason aldean and luke
bryan like every year it's the same
three people um there's more but yeah
but now it's like i don't when i think
of the biggest male country stars like
those three people don't even
come to my blake shelton like it's luke
homes it's morgan wallin like it's these
younger more like
not like outliers but these are they're
just like so conventional these original
three
and i just don't feel like they really
represent country music anymore okay
sure we could have that argument about
like the entertainer of the year right
but when it comes to hosting like i
don't think luke holmes wants to host
the cmas no and he's far too famous to
do that yeah but like luke bryan has
pivoted in his career to be like a
singer but also a tv personality yeah
but don't you feel like this is like a
step down
i just feel like it's a lot of really
hard work for someone who has reached a
level where he doesn't need to work that
hard right anymore right you know and
like it's a a lot of hosting is like a
thankless job but i also think like in
country music and in the cmas it's a
room of your friends
and it's not as like high stakes it's
not a room of people sitting around with
pitchforks like it is in hollywood right
it's just a fun good time yeah it's like
a family evening
and he works with abc on american idol
like there's a country music award on
abc like it's gonna be yeah yeah i guess
that's true
i'm just like i don't know i'm just like
not like other country fans you know
[Music]
yeah
that's just a little bit about me no i i
like this and then i also think adding
peyton manning like gives it the the
little flair and it's so american like
yeah i like i think peyton manning is a
great choice um and i think he's really
funny and personable and he'll do a good
job
and i agree like i think the the
environment at the cma awards is very
much like a friendly environment it's
like welcoming
so it shouldn't be like two high stakes
for anyone yeah
so that's why i don't think
i think it's a pleasure probably to host
and what happened to just like every
year it being carrie underwood and brad
paisley
i mean
i don't know
i feel like for carrick like why would
carry underwood one work that hard
except that like every year she just
like did the most and was the best and
the most gorgeous in every outfit and
that must be fun too yeah but country
music is interesting because like let's
say it was the grammys and they had
taylor swift hosts like the grammy like
the hosting job at traditional award
shows is like it's like a step down from
the people who actually win the award
it's like if you're hosting that's
because you're not a contender
or i mean as what it should be what it
used to be is like a host is a different
job from being a performer which i think
is better and it's usually comedians
yeah
but in country it's always like kelsey
ballerini does it it's like it's always
like huge stars who are also up for a
war yes but we say this we've been
saying this more and more with like new
hosting announcements coming out it's
like it used to be a job like you were a
host or you were an actor or you were a
singer and now like the singers and
actors are the hosts right pushing out
the host but then also we complain at
the same time that the people who are
hosting these things are doing a
terrible job it's like bring back the
host yeah no i don't think having people
host who are also
eligible for awards that night or on the
same level as people who are nominated i
don't think that that is the the right
choice like i think hosts should be
hosts right but also it's like what we
said about laverne cox doing the e-red
carpet yeah and i'll give everyone a
chance and now having seen like i think
maybe it's two award seasons of her work
like it's not the right job for her
she's not particularly good at it
it's just not and that's not me being
critical that's just facts like yeah i
don't think the audience
loved it either no and i would be
surprised if she if she returns whenever
her contract is up also so random but
speaking of like
pop culture
are you following this netflix lawsuit
against the tick talkers no
so i think i've spoken about these
girlies before i actually really like
them i follow them on tick tock they're
two separate girls barlow and bear but
when
abigail barlow and emily bear but when
they work together they're like a duo
barlow and bear i've never even heard of
them and they wrote yes you have they
wrote the unofficial bridgerton musical
like via tiktok like they literally just
started writing and one of them as a
composer one of them is a songwriter so
they put out like all these it went so
viral bridget and the musical i don't
know if you remember
they um did song after song and they
actually ended up with like a completely
fully composed album went viral people
loved it they got nominated for a grammy
and they won
and now they've kind of been on like
this recent press tour just like
performing the bridgeton songs they did
i think at the kennedy center so the
bridgerton songs
it's like songs about bridgerton yeah
it's like if bridgerton was a musical so
it's like if this is what you call a
honeymoon
pacing around our separate rooms
running from our elaborate rooms we're
doomed like it's like like great
red jay john paul and phoebe jennifer
like if they were in the hotel room like
what would they have sung you know yeah
cool and it was really good songs
whatever they won the the grammy it was
like such a big deal and now
netflix is suing them for
so it was our understanding as you know
followers that netflix had approved or
like they had gotten a license like the
album was not made nefariously like it
was fine
but now they're doing performances
of the musical using the bridge or tim
like name and likeness and um netflix
had sent them like a cease and desist
about it and they ignored it and now
netflix is like fully suing them it's
cause like two regular girls are being
sued by netflix yeah that's crazy but
you can't use the bridger to name and
lights out yeah and monetize it and go
on a tour especially after they sent him
a cease and desist yeah they should have
listened to the cease and desist but i
thought that i think they thought like
netflix is billion dollar corporation
it's never gonna go after two little
girls
that's really crazy but the thing about
netflix that i've learned is like
they're extremely petty like they will
go after two little girls
and i guess netflix owns the rights the
name bridgers and not that author
good question
good question
i don't know
it's just an interesting like legal
story unfolding it's like if someone was
running around
doing morning toast musical and like at
first it's like cudin's promoting the
show so sure but then they start like
selling and trading yeah no cease and
desist
100 they're wrong for the for the live
performance part but i also think like
netflix should have um
like leaned into it a little bit more
especially because by the time they were
filming second season the album was out
like this has been going on for a while
and they should have like used one of
the songs at least like instrumentally
in one like i thought they should have
leaned into it more
they have their own thing going on like
yeah there's a lot going on in
bridgerton no for sure but like they
could have done like a separate show but
someone should actually put it on
broadway
in the musical totally totally in
collaboration with netflix and it's like
really good like the music is actually
like stellar it sounds really grammy it
sounds really good what you're just
saying to me yeah no it is that's like
obviously the only part that i know
because that's the part that went like
super viral on tick tock and then the
album
did too thing to me paulo all you have
to do is ask
are you ready for our fifth and final
story just one subject that we can't
quit and it is our human interest story
so we're gonna be talking about the
lottery because
a single man in illinois won the lottery
last week the over billion dollars and i
was a little confused because they keep
saying a single man sorry is he not
married or he wasn't part of a group
um but we came to the conclusion that it
probably means that it just means that
like one singular ticket as opposed to
multiple tickets winning right i mean it
was definitely
heartbreaking for millions of people
including myself around the country i
think it's a disgrace honestly i
definitely think it's rigged i'm
super happy for the guy who won but
obviously like it
alexa play that should be me by justin
bieber like that should be me it really
should yeah so people have magazine has
put together like a list of do's and
don'ts of lottery winners based on prior
winners experiences but also have they
actually told us like who the man is
have you seen a picture no and also in
eight states there is lottery anonymity
laws that you're allowed to stand on
anonymous so i think he might must be in
one of those eight states and we might
never know so if you won the lottery and
they said like you can remain anonymous
or not well i would do it for the
content like
and i would share i would too but then i
think like everyone knowing that i have
a billion dollars in the bank would make
me a target i actually think i would
stay anonymous so it's very possible
that actually i did win
it's possible that i did win and i'll
never tell a single man in illinois yeah
it's possible but like if i won the
lottery honestly like i'd never tell
anyone
except for you obviously like and like
my friends like sit here do the show
every day with like the secret brewing
you can't even like keep together a
secret project no i know but like this
is about my safety
like if everyone knew i had a billion
dollars like people would just start
like tracking me
like it would be like 460 million by the
way when you do the lump sum in taxes
yeah for sure for sure
you wouldn't be a billionaire no but
then i would say 400. why wouldn't they
start go track an actual billionaire
because an actual billionaire has been
so wealthy for so long that like they
have security measures in place right
but i'm vulnerable because i am a new
billionaire and i don't know exactly
like where to put the security cameras
you know yeah
that's the things that that keep me up
at night you're still not a billionaire
though i just want you to know just in a
few years i would be because i would be
smart
unlike some of the people you're about
to listen market is tanking no for sure
but like i would i would be investing
wisely i would be um
like i would i would not spend most of
the money that i won and i would put in
like a high interest yielding so like
every year i'd be making like
tens of millions of dollars just like by
doing nothing okay so don't worry about
me okay that's good well here are some
do's and don'ts in case you are the
single man in illinois who won the
billion dollars that's actually not a
billion dollars sorry to tell you do
follow your dreams whoever said you
can't buy happiness must have had some
inexpensive hobbies for down on his luck
cowboy neil wanliss a 232 million dollar
powerball winner in 2009 it allowed him
to live comfortably while pursuing his
passions at 23 years old he bought a
nearly 50 000
acre ranch in south dakota and in 2020
he told wall street journal that he
stayed grounded thanks to the rewarding
challenges of life on the range oh my
god i love that because you always hear
like the worst stories here's one of the
worst when 19 year old jonathan vargas
and so this is don't related to
elizabeth lynn vargas perhaps this is
don't dream recklessly okay he won 35
million powerball prize in 2008 and he
listened to his heart and invested in
streams in 2010 he created
restless takedown an all-female
wrestling tv show in which he appeared
under the persona jv rich
it ceased production following one
season and he withdrew from the public
eye and expressed some regret for
spending his endeavors okay see the
thing is is like you can dream big when
you win 1.3 billion but like 35 million
it would be surprising how easy it is to
run through 35 million dollars
especially on a tv show of like female
wrestlers like i'm embarrassed for that
man like i really am like he should be
ashamed
do higher guidance you can't win money
management skills in the lottery so
forbes suggests that finding a team of
advisors is a key move in holding on to
the jackpot agreed but there are also so
many managers who will steal your money
right and i imagine that when you win
the lottery like you are inundated and
you're a target for a money manager with
like attorneys and money and business
managers who might have good intentions
and might not
yeah so i would do your due diligence or
have like two people managing your money
so they can keep an eye on each other
yeah
don't be too generous expect everyone
you've ever met to reach out if your
lotto ticket lucks out but with a price
tag attached to each congratulations
irish winner peter lavery who won around
12.8 us doll million us dollars proves
that indeed the road to wealth is not
paved with good intentions over 20 years
after his big win uh he is still rich
and said that he has received thousands
of letters asking for financial support
he said burn them ignore them
ignore them don't open anything if you
don't know who it's from right because
of course it's gonna pull out your
heartstrings um and that's why if he had
remained anonymous he wouldn't have had
that problem wow do give wisely do
true
the best way to give is to give back
pledging money to charities puts you in
control of the amount your anonymity and
for the most part where that donation
will end up
do stay anonymous if possible such a
large sum of money is
bound to grab public attention and in
some states you are legally obligated to
disclose your name like i said and don't
be conspicuous
if you can't stay anonymous then it's
best to keep your lifestyle low key
that's a double entendre not don't be
conspicuous don't colin be conspicuous
oh oh
don't
don't be conspicuous
conspicuous is low-key
right
inconspicuous is located okay now i'm
like my brain
basically like stay out of public life
yeah so uh billy bob harrell jr won 20
million dollars in 1997 two decades
before his home state of texas passed a
bill permitting lottery anonymity and
the 47 year old was incessantly hounded
for money he changed his phone number
several times during the 20 months that
it took to lose his fortune
how much was a fortune 20 million
a million dollars a month
that's terrible and it was in 1997 so a
million dollars was a lot more yeah and
i just feel like there's always been
this stigma of like people from the
lottery like obviously running through
their money and whenever anyone wins
they're like i'm gonna be different like
no one it's like that could never be me
right cut to 20 minutes later
more often than not
oh claudia is like yelling at me every
time i put something on the middle like
we have this gorgeous table in front of
us it's the center piece of our entire
studio and jackie keeps wanting to take
dumps and like put her coffee and her
ipad and her lip gloss and her phone you
being olivia take down
i've been living at olivia's house for
too long i'm starting to exaggerate like
her um i think more often than not
people do squander their good fortune it
would
and i know everyone says it but it will
not be me when i want to actually it
wouldn't be you because you are
extremely physically conservative i am
not cheap
conservative
what sound is that oh my god i thought
that was like the door thinking
do it again
oh my god
i can't even make
those are the past five stories and you
a hundred thousand percent needed to
know that you need to know i think i
felt really good about them i've been
picking the stories while i've been
pumping which gives me a hard 30 minutes
of uninterrupted story picking time i
love that and i actually had seven that
i whittled down to five ooh an
embarrassment of riches yeah much like
the lottery winners
um well the show's not over because it's
monday and we haven't burden yourselves
which is our monday segment where you
can write in and just basically
tell us what you're embarrassed about
like hand over your bird what i have a
funny idea for a show i just want to
throw in sure so it's like someone finds
that they know the town that the
illinois single man and they're like oh
my gosh single man hosted by paddy
sanger so they go to the show or it
could be like a shit's creek like comedy
style show they go to the town and
they're like i'm gonna this single man
and like they said they think they know
who it is and they spend all their time
and efforts on the wrong person right
meanwhile like they're you know they
become best friends with the actual
winner who won't tell anyone but even
though that is shit's creek because at
the end of shit's creek you find out
that twyla won 90 million dollars in the
lottery oh true
i forgot about that part i didn't steal
the plot from shit's creek i like my
version me too me too and i like the
little twist i added too yeah like
that's a really good sitcom idea free
idea i'm not gonna make it toast studios
can't take it on right now free idea
we're putting it on the ether and it's
all yours yeah just don't [ __ ] it up
oh also um spoiler
alert rupaul's dragons
about where paul's dragons rupaul's drag
race winner announced um i did
accidentally spoil it for myself but i
don't care because i was so thrilled
with the winner um james monsoon i
wanted her to win i believed in her from
the very mo okay that's a lie like at
first i was like why was she cast but
then once i really saw the power of the
monsoon i was so happy and i just want
to say like i was right and i am
overjoyed and you were wrong more
importantly i that's totally fine by me
yeah no and i was right so i just think
that's important you know
that i was right that you were right
about the show that you watch right that
i don't like yeah yeah yeah you should
be no i'm gonna take the w however i can
you know yeah yeah a win is a win no
matter how you saw yourself i like that
we like put our
boats in you know because then we had
something we had skinny steak yeah
um okay so i was actually saying
something before you enjoy sorry i just
had to get my show idea out there
unburden yourselves our monday segment
you can email unburden yourselves at
gmail.com with something that's
burdening you like something you feel
really embarrassed of something you did
over the weekend or in past weekends
that's just been plaguing you and once
you write it to us you're officially
letting it go we will make you feel
better about it and once it's done like
it's done you know what it reminds me of
like plea the fifth it's like just this
arbitrary idea yet it carries so much
weight 100 it's like yeah you might be
worried about this for so long but like
if you write it in and we read it like
you have to let it go you just have to
that's the rules 100
and unburden yourselves is brought to
you by thrive cosmetics so thrive
cosmetics which i have actually used
because i bought from a facebook ad like
literally five years ago because their
mascara looked so good and it was that
good is a fabulous um
beauty company that has fabulous eye
products and skin care products like the
liquid lash extensions mascara that's
the one i was talking about it is the
best selling product it has more than
twenty thousand five star reviews it is
ultra lengthening eye opening mascara
that lasts all day without clumping
smudging or flaking and it mimics the
look of lash extensions without the
damaging glue or expensive salon prices
also they have great skin care products
like the defying gravity eye lifting
cream it instantly lifts tightens and
brightens skin around your eyes with
line smoothing hydration you can soften
smooth and deeply moisturize while
instantly reducing dark circles and
puffiness it feigns signs of stress
aging and dullness it's like beauty
sleep in a bottle also thrive cosmetics
it's spelled c-a-u-s-e because they are
a cause-driven cause-driven brand so um
they partner with better than beauty for
every product purchase thrive cosmetics
donates to help communities thrive they
have over 300 giving partners across the
country supporting numerous courses so
now's a great time to try thrive
cosmetics for yourself right now you can
get 15 off your first order when you
visit thrivecosmetics.com
toast that's thrive cosmetics cosmetics
is spelled c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s
thrive cause medics dot com slash toast
for 15 off your first order i love it
are you ready to unburden yourself i'm
ready you want to read them today
i'm having like poor eyesight i can't
explain as long as like you won't call
me out
by the way an unwritten slash unspoken
rule of the toast is like we can make
fun of each other for pronouncing things
differently unless it's in an ad or a
deer toasters or like which is an unfair
rule because you read those and what i
read is not part of the rule i didn't
say it was a fair rule i just said it
was a rule i think it should apply the
past five stories those are sacred too
by the way do they not apply to fast
forward no you just called me out for
saying dwayne johnson tweeted diseases
okay we'll officially include that under
the image so many times i read the story
and you sit there like
wait for me to finish i never thought
about that you're 100 right like
fast five reading
is also it is sacred it's it should be
i think all reading is off limits a
hundred percent oh my god she's trying
our best imagine if you're in class and
you're reading out loud in the class and
you mispronounce something it's
disgusting one of the kids was like
tweezers cosmetics yeah
okay
first up hi jackson claude oh claude
with an e like claude monette blood clod
i absolutely love the toast and your
florida vibes are immaculate thank you
so much girlie okay so i'm a pta mom and
we had a school auction that was themed
neon nights everyone wore near neon
colors and glow sticks and anything glow
in the dark i was new to the school and
super excited to be at this event
needless to say i went a little
overboard with group shots and stayed
out way too late i vaguely remember
dancing with other people's husbands but
not much after that
fast forward to the morning i wake up
and only my glow sticks my p-jump
husband brought me home of course i
threw up so he undressed me and put me
in the bed had the absolute worst
anxiety on sunday going to school drop
off that monday carried a little more
stress than normal our school community
is awesome though and so fun so no one
said anything i'll never forget the
naked glow stick shame well thanks for
burdening me keep florida toast going
love you too okay i just want to say
like i was a little worried until you
said your husband was there and your
husband like
wasn't as drunk as you like he will
protect you so honestly i don't think
you could have done anything that bad
also you said like that's the vibe of
like the school community so you
probably weren't like the worst one
there and some lessons like truly do
need to be learned the hard way like
you'll just remember the way you feel
the next time you want to get blacked
out at pta night you know right but a
few things like first of all any pta
that's theme is neon knights is trying
to twist it's turn no they're trying to
get rowdy yeah and
the uh every party needs a good party
animal like so that was you it's just
crazy that you would think that like
once you're a pta mom like your crazy
days are behind you crazy days are
behind you like moral hangovers
anxieties behind you
and no like you could always still be
that girl and that's actually a
promising message and i feel like a lot
of people worry like when i become a mom
like i won't be fun anymore like where
am i going to go to the best party and
it's like no join the pta we have neon
nights you'll wake up naked with glow
sticks i need to know where you live
it's a good time it's reminding me of
the movie bad moms yeah yeah yeah like
also
you know i don't think other moms like
would really judge you because sometimes
like you just need as a mom like you
just need to let go and like go wild so
i don't think it's really a big deal at
all i don't think it's a big deal but i
also think that you've done like the
community a service and sharing your
story because it lets other people know
that like you can still be doing these
things as a mom like opportunities will
present themselves yeah like don't be
afraid to have kids like you can still
get blacked out yeah and you're not
going to be at one oak you're going to
be at the pta meeting you're going to be
in the gymnasium with glow sticks fun
fun if you drink enough the gymnasium
can turn into one oak yeah i mean i
would rather be in a gymnasium than at
one oak honestly a hundred percent a
hundred percent right like
you're probably wearing comfortable
clothes
i really don't think this is a big deal
at all i think you can like release your
anxiety um
and just
maybe take it like a little easier next
time a pta night but not even like it
sounds like everyone was getting that
wasted so you were just like doing what
everyone else was doing you're just a
follower yeah
you're fine
you're fine number two okay jackson
claud this one's the doozy so i went out
with a group of friends to bring in the
new year and in order to save money we
decided to pre-game at a friend's house
before heading out well pre-gaming
turned into me drinking a majority of a
bottle of patron to myself once we got
to the club i was completely drunk off
my ass but i was walking talking and
dancing so i didn't think i was that far
gone oh no i can't even keep up with you
oh wow keep going by the way it's hard
to follow the stories when you're the
not reader is what i've i've experienced
in my not reading position okay i'll let
you know if that is the case but you
were just going so [ __ ] fast
she drank a whole bottle of patron
our group decided that they wanted to go
to a different club for the countdown so
we rallied the troops and went to leave
this was where disaster struck on the
way out there's a set of six-ish stairs
you have to go down and i made it about
halfway before i tripped and took the
entire velvet rope down with me
all three bouncers ran to help me i
swore i was fine but my thumb hurt a
little bit my friends told me i looked
fine and that was that so or so i
thought flash forward to the next
morning i'm on facetime with my cousin
complaining about how hungover i am when
i go to toss my hair a habit i do all
the time and find my curls have been
dried up in my vomit from last night it
was crunchy to the touch and took three
weeks with three washes just to get the
stench off and to top it all off i did
in fact sprained my thumb and had to
wear a brace for two weeks while it
healed i've never been so embarrassed
and disgusted with myself all at once
needless to say i will be staying away
from patron for the rest of eternity and
staying my ass home for new year's
okay i just want to say like that is
vile like that is so disgusting to have
slept with vomit in your hair but like
at least you weren't like sleeping with
a guy or like you you were the only one
who saw it so it's not embarrassing what
makes this totally fine is that it was
new years and yes
new year's like everything is absolved
it's a new year what you did last year
is none of your business 100
and
if there's ever like a universal night
to go balls to the walls and wake up
with vomiting your hair
and so for that
you're absolved you're unburdened and
like nobody saw it like yes you could
sit and like have anxiety over the fact
like you did something and like you
can't believe it got that far but like
literally nobody saw so just pretend it
never happened yeah and you got the
stench out of your hair so you're good
you're good you're totally fine but
that's a lot but you're good i hope your
thumb's okay the thumb is what's tough
like you need your thumb otherwise
you'll be a stress brother useless no
opposable thumbs useless brothers
brothers sitting sleeping through the
work day truly
number three hi jackson claude i love
y'all i didn't realize so many people
write claude as with an e at the end
honestly in my couple years of doing all
the readings i've really never seen
anyone do an a that's weird though that
two today
two-thirds
hi jackson claude i love you all so much
and congrats on one year of spritz i'm a
big pineapple and peach girlie so thank
you for making such a premium product
you're so welcome and i love peach as
well welcome
what can i say except yeah welcome
my anxiety story is four years old and i
still have nightmares about it oh girl
we've all been there okay it's time to
on this burden we're gonna help you i
was getting over a heartbreak and was
really feeling down on myself i was out
of town for work in a state literally
across the country so did you take the
i-95
me and some work friends went out to a
bar one night and the alcohol was
flowing i decided to get on bumble
bumble and to my excitement i matched
with someone in the city i typically
invited him to the bar what's that uh
who speaks like that wait hold on no
no
yeah yeah i do
i invited
but what is the word that she says when
she says that
herb herb linger i think it's from that
little
in the leave a picturesque ridge lies a
small unpretentious one right
whatever
it's annoying me now i dipped silly
invited him to the bar and by the time
he showed up i was full-on drunk we went
back to my hotel room and started to
hook up and obviously her boss right oh
i don't know i didn't even think about
that and i literally fell asleep during
it i know this because when i woke up
alone might i add he had written me a
note letting me know what happened i was
mortified what's worse is the door to my
hotel room was left partially open and i
couldn't remember the details of what we
did before i fell asleep i couldn't find
remnants of a condom so i called my
friend and we went to the hotel cbs and
i bought plan b at least my co-worker
had a cbs coupon so it was 20 off i
learned my lesson and i've not put
myself in a situation like that ever
since thanks for letting me unburden
myself even though i think i will feel
shame for how dumb i was forever
not dumb like literally
people take plan b all the time yeah no
but like sleeping with the hotel door
open like right she has nightmares about
like what could have happened of course
but it sounds like the door was left
open because he left yeah
and maybe it was just like one of those
doors that like just doesn't slam shut
behind you it needs to be like pulled
and i don't know if i would have like
necessarily the biggest pit because it
sounds like he left a note he was
somewhat respectful like everything i
think what she has anxiety about it's
like everything was fine but it could
have happened right like like she
happened to go home with a guy was
extremely respectful slept with the door
open and nobody came in and robbed her
like everything went right and that
never happens yeah so she always it's
just thinking about like the potential i
think about that
all the time when i get in situations
where like
it could have been so much worse and
then i have a pit about like how could i
be so dumb how could i put myself in
that situation
like and having you know nightmares
about it four years later
but it's also a lesson an important
lesson yeah and probably learning that
lesson then in in what turned out to be
like a positive an okay environment um
stopped you from learning it in a worse
environment that's so true actually and
it's just sad like those are one of
those like some lessons just have to be
learned like that like and you should
just feel but i know exactly what you're
saying like sometimes i feel that way
remember when i capsize i know this is
like a very random um
analogy but when i capsized in the
delaware
and it was literally freezing and i was
like freaking out and i was never really
in any actual danger because i was close
to the shore and also ben and brian were
in two different um kayaks next to me
but i always think like because it was
it wasn't summer it was like
between
winter and spring it was really cold you
can get really caught in a rapid like so
many terrible things have happened in
like rivers and stuff and i always think
like how dumb i [ __ ] am like and how
much worse it could have been and like
honestly i've been on the river since
then it like freaked me that was the
lesson for you like the river the river
it's like or did you do something on the
kayak that caused you to capture i was
being reckless i was drinking i was
wearing a life vest but like it just it
highlighted the importance of like
things can go wrong really quickly and
like you can't be a dumb [ __ ] yeah
that's a lesson we've all been there
right so
i would feel grateful for the experience
and for the lesson yeah and that it
happened and everything was okay and
that now you know better yeah and those
were the unburden yourselves that were
brought to you by spirit society again
this is the one year anniversary of
sprit society and we are celebrating on
our website with birthday bundles so you
are getting a great price for a bundle
of spritz and they're also themed after
your girlies our favorite flavors we
also have signed some sickening
unsolated wine tumblers insulated wine
tumblers and they're also unslated and
that's a part that sets us apart
um they're available at spritsociety.com
and that is our show so
thank you all so much for listening to
the morning to us the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube sure
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so spotify itunes stitch or public
radio i heard radio cast box all the
places wherever you listen to the
podcast find us more until sleep a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have an
incredible incredible day and we'll see
you tomorrow we'll see you tomorrow bye